and what we're seeing more and more is
really just a mental health crisis in
this country you know when you have an
entire generation of people that grew up
with fighting parents single mother
homes and really a gender War
I mean that's what it is a war on men
um you you really do get mental
disorders you know
um a couple weeks ago uh maybe a couple
months ago now
um I was with I was with blessing in
America and you know we had a flight
um to go I think it was from LA to Vegas
no no it was vague it was Vegas to
Chicago and so we were late to the
airport and we were trying to make this
flight and we missed this flight by 10
minutes guys
and you know it was her own fault we
left late whatever
um
so then we had to wait we knew we had to
wait for the next flight which was like
four hours but whatever it happens we
weren't pressed
um next to us there was a girl that
actually also missed her flight
this girl guys I never thought I never
thought I would see this in person this
chick
laid on the floor and started screaming
now guys I've I've this day I didn't
have anywhere to be so I was fine
um I felt like that before okay I've had
that thought there have been times where
I've this isn't my first flight I've
missed shocking I know where I I I
understand the feeling but she was like
20 something and this grown ass lady
was crying on the floor
and
um I just I just couldn't believe it I
was I was like and it's funny because a
lot of times what they'll say is social
media isn't real life and you know what
I'll say at first it's not so 10 years
ago when I saw Caitlyn Jenner on the
screen of my TV that wasn't real life
but now it's 10 years later and
tournaments that I play in and my little
sisters now because they're in sports
it becomes real life so it might not
start off as real life but what happens
is a lot of these Trends start in the
cities you might be in the suburbs or
the country and slowly but surely they
come to you
you know um just because you want to
walk away from the craziness that's
going on it doesn't protect your kids
from it it doesn't protect the schools
from it
unless you become literally Amish
um so now I'm in the airport this lady's
skirt like screaming on the floor and we
go to rebook the flight she's like
yelling at the at the flight attendant I
swear I looked at her and I was like
this is your own fault because she was
she was literally trying to blame she
was trying to blame the flight
attendants because the plane they closed
the doors like five minutes before the
flight opened or whatever and she got
there like right as the flight is
supposed to take off and I'm thinking
this lady's freaking nuts it's your own
fault then get there you know what I
mean like you know I I missed it too I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna cry
but you see these people with a mental
like literally mental disorders and
another phenomenon that I see just from
interviewing women after women after
women
is really these chicks having mental
disorders
um to the point where you interview
women on the street you say rate
yourself one to ten they say ten why do
they think that because the attention
they're getting is the level of a 10 10
years ago we get so much attention from
Instagram
um the likes we edit our pictures we
literally think we look different and
it's so interesting because they come on
the show and sometimes I'll follow them
after the show I don't know I'm a nice
I'm a nice gal occasionally and
it's so crazy sometimes I don't even
recognize them
so there is an Instagram famous model
that a meltdown on a plane when she says
she left to avoid knocking seat mate the
F out let's pull it up call me a
again yeah you guys did nothing wrong no
you shut the up you shut the
up in here
film me I'm Instagram famous
how many social media commentators these
Instagram are broke
they're literally oh so she's an only
fans model
wow of course of course I'm shocked
and so do you see this delusion now
she's she thinks she's so important
because she sells her ass pictures and
the thing is you got about a 10-year
shelf life and then you're done if
you're not insightful if you're not
smart there's nothing you're just done
in the in the especially if all you're
selling is sex good luck okay they said
so what do you do I'm a model on
Instagram you I'm a soldier on Call of
Duty
wow wow
and you know this this is delusion and
it's so interesting because I see this
like culture and my mom and my dad just
always told me and I'm not saying I'm
perfect at this but for the most part
like no matter what people are doing to
you like just stay calm like the person
that first gets a rise out of you
they're they lost you lose
and you know it's so interesting because
people get like they always it's always
over like disrespect and the thing is
people are so soft when it comes to like
people just take freaking everything is
disrespect
yeah but you know it's so interesting
because these this stuff really does
start just online you think oh it's not
real life
wait five years
wait 10 years
wait your kids are going to talk to
these people